Jake Olson USC long snapper got in the
game he is legally blind and a pretty
amazing story and I got to give a lot of
credit to Western Michigan as well and
their coach Tim Lester to be able to
allow this to happen and Jake taking
time to join us now Jake first of all
congratulations how did you feel about
it I mean it was obviously a long time
waiting for a lot of practice when it
went into that and you know uh between
my team and just basically everyone
involved through our Trojan nation I
mean it was just a long time like you
said we've been waiting for it and it
was just it was great to actually see it
happen what did you hear when you walked
onto the field well you know it's
focused definitely I'm just trying to
tap into my my technique and feel but
you know you definitely hear the crowd
cheering and again you know I feel
nothing but love and support in that
Stadium and just from all the Trojan
nations so you know as much as the
pressure was of a stadium full of people
it really you know it's a stadium full
of people that are just rooting the heck
out of you I couldn't help but think of
your parents in that moment Jake with
obviously with everything you've been
through but your parents they're
watching but they can't do anything for
you did you talk to them about how you
know what they were thinking when you
were going into the game yeah I mean I I
alerted them before for the game I was
probably going so they were very excited
I mean they were just very ecstatic for
me you know I started two years in high
school and varsity and ours Lutheran so
listen it's nothing new for me to have
game game time played but it's it for
you know obviously had a much bigger
stage and then just a story behind it
was it was awesome how nervous were you
I was nervous the days leading up and
you know obviously that morning just
because I realized what I was about to
go do is probably bigger than obviously
just a PA to Santa it was it had a lot
more meaning just from a sports aspect
so that that really was kind of what the
nervous was I you know I I believed in
my taking
I believe in obviously my muscle memory
just cuz you know snap you know thousand
thousands of times and you know we
practice so it's it wasn't dad just was
more wow this is gonna be a huge moment
that everyone's gonna remember for the
rest of life and you know I just I
wanted to make sure I deliver just
because there's there was just so much I
guess to be learned from that and to be
inspired from that you know I really
wanted just to prove to people I could
well it feels like we're making it
bigger than what you're making it like
you you've done it before and okay it's
a bigger crowd and bigger stage but
because it's a great it's an
unbelievable story Jake yeah I
appreciate that I mean you know I do
recognize that I mean it's uh it you
know I guess because I do that practice
every day and you know um you know it is
it's just something that I've done like
said thousand times but you know again I
I do realize that inspires people and
that's you know that's what I love with
with all the coverage for I mean I was
just hearing how people are inspired and
touched by to move it by is something
that in return inspires me and that's
and that's really something that I love
hearing he said Jake Olson the unc long
snapper what's next well obviously more
games you know i just want to want to
get in there and and keep proving myself
and you know that's i got i got two more
seasons here so just want to continue
moving and move on and not just allow
this to be a one-time experience if
you'll explain and i know you have but
if you can for a national audience of
how you lost your eyesight i would
appreciate that yes I was about eight
months old the doctors found a rare for
my cancer in my eyes called
retinoblastoma and they had to almost
immediately remove my left eye and then
through radiation chemotherapy were able
to say my right eye and then basically
for the next 12 years that cancer came
back around seven times on the eighth
time the doctors pretty much said when
this was when I was twelve years old
back in 2009 the doctor said that really
there was no more treatment that could
affect the cancer and the the scare and
the danger really is that the tumor
moves from the retina to the through the
optic nerve
the brain and then from there it's
pretty much unstoppable so that's why
the removal of the eyes kind of
necessary in situations in which they
think the cancer is untreatable that
night before surgery that week before
surgery and you're what 12 years of age
what do you what do you well that was
the one of the more awesome things about
the USC experience with when as part of
that team with Coach Carroll is just
when I was here on campus when I was in
practice it really really was a hedge of
protection and safety and my mind really
wasn't on that next day it really wasn't
on what I was gonna confront it was more
just that pure joy and bliss being being
with my heroes on the Trojan team but it
was scary I mean you know it's sad I
remember that the morning of my surgery
you know I remember driving up the
hospital and you're trying to implant
all the sights of you know the beach or
cars or the building's la like whatever
I could see has one kind of implant that
cuz I mean that that was one of the
toughest things are just knowing you
know this was the last time I was gonna
be able to see these things and when you
know when I was heading back home it you
know I wouldn't be able to so that was
that was kind of the thing that really
was a burden on my heart and just my
mind it was just understanding this mean
the last time I saw these things and
your parents last time you see them I
mean that's yeah I mean that was
obviously that was the hardest part just
to be able to see my parents faces and
you know I remember seeing my dad's face
and it's just I've never seen so much
pain in a face before and you know it
was something that they you know they
were they they went through with me and
you know I mentioned this after the game
but just to know how much hurt they've
gone through just either baby boy go and
go blind but just to see and what
motivates me is just to go out there and
show them that okay you know I've gone
through this long they still thrive I'm
not gonna let this this you know turn my
life apart and so I want to give them
those moments of pure joy and hope that
outweighs the moments that were very
tough are you still playing golf
I am yeah I'm a big golfer only I don't
get out as much in the fall but yeah I'm
a huge golfers though explain because
you know I have guys I work with the
dinettes they're just picking up
off and then I said you know Jake I
think shoots in the 80s they would shoot
in the 80s on the front nine Jake so
what is it about golf you can't see I
know that does your dad help you or you
go out with him and then he lines you up
right so basically what's happening
I was a really good golfer before going
blind and I wanted to keep that up so in
the beginning when back when I was 12 is
just making a solid contact and
advancing the swing from there and a lot
of it was muscle memory and just honing
in that feel and understanding what
would this we needed to be like to
produce a great shot and that's where
really I learned muscle memory and that
brings me back to snapping but with golf
yeah so basically dad would just put the
club behind the ball make sure the bolts
under the club stays closed faces at the
target I'd take my stance and then he
just would back up and then from there
just you know my swinging and so it you
know it was a it's a lot a lot of work a
lot of again just going out there
understanding okay that was a that was a
shot that was good those are those bad
and you know eventually gives you get to
a point where it's just like every other
golfer you know okay you're putting a
little more draw on the ball today you
know it was like let's feel it out let's
see what you know what you might be
doing is your wrist coming through to
flake or your you know your hips not
clearing as much whatever the case may
be so a lot of it I mean for any golfers
just being able to go in there tap into
that feel feel the swing feel maybe what
what what's going on on a day where
maybe you're not producing the shots
that you want and yeah I mean eventually
you just get to a point where it is just
a consistent thing I mean you know you
just become a machine out there and
that's my goal just become a machine out
there and yeah I mean over over the
summer I was shooting in the 70s and it
was you know it's just something that
you got to practice and just trust in
your swing and I said if the ball just
sitting there to be hit I know it sounds
that it's not that easy trust me I
understand that but it is something that
you deliver a great swing you know that
you will get your you see now Jake
you're being a show-off when you say you
can shoot in the 70s now you're being a
show-off is what you're doing all right
yeah I'll play with people in it is kind
of it's kind of probably bad for the
game of golf just the sport of the hole
and discouragement when you get beat by
a blind golfer
you could take money from people your
dad could go up to the first tee and go
well you know we'll play you and then
all of a sudden you know you they'll be
giving you a couple strokes there and
you know first hole may be like shaken
you just throw them off all right yeah
absolutely
we got to get you in the UCLA game I
think that's that that's the next move
here right yeah no III really I really
that would be that would be awesome and
that would always be probably something
that is a goal in mind for sure just to
be able to say I played against the boys
across town well it was fun
it was a great moment Congrats to your
parents too because they went through
that moment every bit as you did and
Jake we appreciate the time I know that
swim with Mike program Jake got a
scholarship that's raised millions of
dollars over the last 40 years it goes
to scholarships towards physically
challenged athletes all over the country
the origin was for a paralyzed USC
all-american swimmer and started out a
swim for Mike to raise money for him at
morphed into swim for Mike now and a lot
of places besides USC to raise money
great story Jake and congratulations
thanks for joining us all right that's
Jake Olson the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience